lot of snow at Lee Canyon our own
Madison Kimbrough made the Trek up the
mountain today joins us with a look
ahead at the festivities this Easter
weekend
snow because it's a four-day weekend for
several students across the valley and
take a look as it's one of the busiest
days they've had on the slopes this year
this is pretty amazing the snowfall that
we had this year record snowfall means
more time on the mountain from skiers to
snowboarders to those just enjoying the
crisp powder I caught up with some
locals and tourists who can't believe
they get to experience this
that in April this is like my first time
seeing snow and everything usually you
can't really like get this snow and like
go snowboarding this late in the year
and it's like really fun I didn't think
that they had like even this here in
Vegas so like it's crazy this weekend
the activities are non-stop according to
Lee Canyon marketing director Jim Seeley
I'm sure we'll see a lot of onesies this
weekend it's Easter so uh we'll see if
we can count how many Easter bunnies we
can see this weekend as well also an
Easter egg hunt will take place where
day pass holders can explore the ski
trails Seeley mentioning how they've
seen a massive uptick in business this
season due to the amount of snow one of
the main reasons they've extended their
season I think our snowfall is more than
260 inches of natural snowfall through
the season you know that's a record
beating our 2005 record after this
weekend the canyon will be open Friday
through Sunday that's going to be until
the end of April now spots are limited
so make sure to book online reporting
here at Lake Canyon Madison Kimbrough 8
News Now